la parole est à monsieur axel
poniatowski pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le premier ministre lundi 16
novembre devant le congrès françois
hollande annoncé son intention de former
une coalition internationale contre
l'état islamique impliquant ainsi un
rapprochement inattendu mais bienvenu
avec la russie dans la foulée moscou
changer aussi son positionnement en
exigeant de sa marine qu'elle coordonne
ses opérations en méditerranée avec la
marine française la franche profondément
meurtri et bouleversé par les attentats
du 13 novembre et ses 130 morts et la
russie toujours sous le choc des 224
personnes tuées dans un avion de ligne
au dessus du sinaï que vous évoquez ont
procédé l'une et l'autre à une révision
à 180° de leurs relations bilatérales et
décidé de coopérer contre l'ennemi
commun le plus dangereux du moment
l'état islamique
cette actualité ses conséquences
auraient peut-être amené la france à
revoir sa position à quelques semaines
près quand lé livraison des navires
mistral
mais le passé est le passé aujourd'hui
monsieur le premier ministre
le moment est venu d'engager le
processus de levée des sanctions
économiques européennes à l'égard de la
russie
je rappelle qu'elles ont été je rappelle
qu'elles ont été prorogés en juin 2015
jusqu'au 31 janvier 2016 qui
apparaissent désormais décalé et surtout
plus du tout à la mesure d'une approche
sereine de nos divergences
cette initiative permettrait de plus de
lever l'embargo russe à l'égard des
produits agricoles et agroalimentaires
dont souffrent les agriculteurs
européens et français
ma question ma question monsieur le
premier ministre
quelles initiatives comptez vous prendre
au sujet de la levée des sanctions
économiques à l'égard de la russie et de
quelle manière
car cette situation va devenir de plus
en plus paradoxale entre alliés je vous
remercie
merci la parole est un monsieur mathias
fekl secrétaire d'état chargée du
commerce extérieur de la promotion du
tourisme et des français de l'étranger
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
axel poniatowski
je vous demande d'abord d'excuser
l'absence du ministre affaires
étrangères monsieur fabius
mais comme cela était inquiet par le
premier ministre avant moi il est en ce
moment même avec le nid de la défense et
avec le président de la république à
washington pour rencontrer le président
obama précisément dans le cadre de la
construction de la grande coalition de
lutte contre des ch et la diplomatie
française est totalement mobilisé sur ce
sujet des échanges ont eu lieu lundi
avec le premier ministre britannique
ils ont lieu aujourd'hui avec le
président obama
ils auront lieu demain avec la
chancelière merkel et jeudi avec le
président poutine
j'en viens donc à la rue ce sujet sujet
fondamental
évidemment d'où les échanges d'abord il
n'y a pas eu d'inflexion à 180% de la
position française le premier cela
rappelait avant moi
ce qui a changé c'est l'état d'esprit de
la russie
c'est l'attentât terrible qui a frappé
un avion russe et c'est toutes les
conséquences qui ont sont tirés
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
la réalité des rapports de force et la
réalité internationale et c'est aussi en
matière de diplomatie
le calme et la sérénité de l'analyse
c'est ce que fait la france
aujourd'hui nous travaillons donc avec
la russie pour construire cette
coalition
sans oublier qu'il ya par ailleurs le
processus de mise qu'il ya par ailleurs
un certain nombre de réalités aux portes
de l'europe et rien de moins que la
guerre ou la paix aux portes de l'europe
et donc nous devons prendre en compte
l'ensemble de ces éléments la lutte
contre des ch et le processus de mix
nous en tirerons toutes les sons toutes
les conséquences le ministre de
l'agriculture s'est déjà rendu en russie
pour travailler sur les aspects agricole
nous sommes en permanence mobilisés y
compris sur les questions économiques
pour trouver des débouchés aux produits
agricoles français regardons les
problèmes les uns après les autres et
mai
chacun au bon niveau merci la parole est
à monsieur olive